would will smith need to be de-aged or
is that infamous alternate ending going
to come into play what megastar is
joining smith all that and more right
here in 2007 will smith once again
cemented his place as one of hollywood's
most charismatic movie stars when he
played the lead in i am legend the film
takes place in a post-apocalyptic world
where most humans have either been wiped
out or turned into vampiric mutants
known as dark seekers i am legend
follows the efforts of smith's dr robert
neville the sole human living in an
overrun manhattan as he tries to find a
cure for the disease that changed the
world and hopefully link up with other
human survivors the movie is a loose
adaptation of the 1954 richard matheson
novel of the same name i am legend
what's a box office success when it was
released in december 2007 earning over
585 million dollars worldwide according
to box office mojo plus they received
generally positive reviews from both
critics and casual moviegoers alike now
over a decade after the first film's
release will smith is set to star in an
i am legend sequel and he isn't the only
notable actor attached to the project in
march 2022 deadline reported that smith
had signed on to star in and executive
produce a sequel to i am legend shortly
after the report's release smith
seemingly confirmed the news on
instagram when he posted an image of the
post-apocalyptic version of manhattan
from the first film in addition to smith
the sequel will also star black panther
and creed actor michael b jordan who is
set to executive produce the film
alongside his coaster akiva goldsman who
co-wrote the 2007 adaptation of i am
legend is set to write the sequel
however it's unclear if i am legend
filmmaker francis lawrence will return
to helm the sequel or if it will be
another filmmaker who ultimately sits in
the director's seat for the follow-up
the film's plot is similarly unknown
right now and it does not currently have
a set release date asked about the
announcement in a recent interview with
entertainment tonight smith teased i
can't talk about it yet but it's a
really really cool concept and michael b
jordan was a part of creating the idea
it was one of those movies i was gonna
leave alone smith also admitted that he
quickly reconsidered once he heard the
pitch for the sequel as he told
entertainment tonight he remembers
thinking but that might work i think we
can do that with two massive styles like
jordan and smith attached to the project
it seems safe to assume that it won't
take too long for more updates and
details to start surfacing about iom
legend 2. one of the updates i am legend
fans undoubtedly most curious about is
how smith plans to appear in the
upcoming film especially considering his
character's apparent death at the climax
of the first movie while no plot details
about the film have been released as yet
that leaves plenty of room for
speculation
just fishing in the dark son
one potential answer could involve a
mixture of flashbacks and the aging
software to return dr neville back to
his pre-apocalyptic or mid-apocalyptic
image there likely remains plenty of
story to be told about the immediate
three years after the outbreak of the
crippen virus of course smith is no
stranger to hollywood's aging practices
as a result of his role in 2019's gemini
man a film which sees smith's character
battle a younger version of himself
admittedly however this might be one of
the more predictable avenues writers
could employ another possible route that
returns dr neville to the big screen
involves an alternate ending to the
original 2007 film the theatrical cut of
iron legend sees dr neville sacrifice
himself in order to save a cure for the
future of mankind on its face this scene
is extremely unambiguous and by the end
of the theatrical cut dr neville is dead
however arden fans of the film will also
surely remember an alternate ending
included on the dvd release in addition
to proving popular online the ultimate
ending is noted for its closer
dedication to the source material
instead of concluding with a dramatic
sacrifice this ending presents dr
neville with the opportunity to make
peace with the dark seekers he has been
trying to cure for so long realizing
that his experiments have instead made
him the monster dr neville abandoned his
research and home making peace with his
new reality dr neville instead opts to
join a group of human survivors in
vermont
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]